لا يفكر الناس أبدًا في القدوم إلى هونغ
كونغ لاستكشاف الطبيعة ، فالكبار المصرفيين ،
مجرد قفزة ملموسة عندما تذهب
لتسلق المدينة ، تفتقد إلى
الطبيعة والمزيج الذي لا أعتقد أنه
يمكنك العثور عليه في أي مكان آخر في العالم
[موسيقى]
Darmok هو  تقع في نوع من قاعدة سانتا
لا تبعد سوى ساعة واحدة عن المدينة ، لذا
يمكنك المشاركة ربما ثلاث ساعات
خلال عطلة نهاية الأسبوع ، وبعد ذلك يمكنك
إطلاق حمل الحمل القائم على العبء الذي لا
يمشي لأنه يشبه الأسد
وهو واحد من  التسلق التقني في
هونغ كونغ
مهما كان الأمر كذلك ، ما الذي فقدته
[موسيقى]
حسنًا. سالي مرحباً ، مقالة توم حول
حديقة المقطورات أو المرح في وقت لاحق ،
لا تذهب لتوضح لهم كيف تخبرهم
أنها زاوية هادئة لتوم أو غارمين
شيء مدهش عندما ترى أنك
تتحسن وأنت راضٍ جدًا ،
أعتقد أن هذا هو السبب في أنني أحب التسلق يساعدك على
أن تصبح شاعراً أفضل ،
هيا ، لكن أوه ، نعم ، أنا أذهب في عطلة نهاية الأسبوع
هيوكوه كل ثلاثة أشهر ، نحن نشرب الكحوليات
جيدًا بعيدًا عن الكعكة.
تعال هنا ج  يا للناس الذين يموتون أمريكا حسناً ، فإن
الفيكتوار هي شيء هولا عندما
تصل إلى القمة ،
إنه أمر رائع يمكنك التغاضي عن
اللون الكامل حتى جزيرة هونج كونج أنت
من هذه المدينة إذا لم
تستكشف الطبيعة فسوف تدهشك
[موسيقى]